bien maintenant or michel rocard eux
jamais été président si c'était à
refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil une seule chose
m mon mandat en balance sur un mauvais
résultat à l'élection européenne
ouais pour me faire jeter sur et hasard
par mauvaise foi et raté parloir
l'investiture
si ma faute tactique que quand vous avez
perdu européenne vous n'auriez pas dû
partir finalement besoin du reste est
oui alors il avait un an et demi avant
reprocher à laurent fabius de n'avoir
pas fait ce que tous les grands
dirigeants européens font ce qu'ils ont
perdu on s'en va ouais je fais partie de
cette race est aussi ma dignité
je suis parti chez une faute tactique
mais au moins dans la dignité
or allez le voir remercie